this is a production of cornell
university
so in today's seminar i'm going to talk
about the agronomic effects
which includes uh benefits and costs or
trade-offs of disease resistance
in maze hybrids with focus on northern
leaf flight
as a case study
some fourier diseases uh can have a
negative
impact on acl for example northern leaf
blight
uh caused by the foliar pathogen
cytospheria torsica
is a major endemic follower disease that
can cause
serious serious yield losses in males
growing regions
worldwide in the u.s and canada alone
this disease was responsible for
roughly 14 million
song losses in 2015
so this information highlights the
importance of resistance breeding
to minimize the negative impact of this
disease
genetic resistance is an effective and
sustainable
uh this is management strategy but it
can be associated with
uh cost with yield costs or trade-offs
however the agronomic effects of
resistance
or maybe this relationship is not
universal because the
agronomic effects of resistance are
variable
and must be a study on a case-by-case
basis
in maze for instance in the presence yes
or an absence no of three different
diseases
anthracnose style rot northernly flight
and sword and lift light
where near osogenic lines with a single
disease qtl
were tested in the asr and the slb case
and several cycles of recurrent
selection
were used in the nlp case
uh resistant plants show at the yield
benefits
in the presence of the disease in the
absence of the disease
those resistant plant or the yield of
those resistant plants
were was not affected in the asr and the
nlp case however
some modest yield cost
associated with resistance alleles
were observed in the slb case
this result confirms that the
yield effects of resistance are variable
across different mace battle systems
extra layers of complexity when studying
and managing the trade-offs
are the underlying genetics and the and
the environment
platoon or linkage are the genetic
forces
that underlie the trade-off but
epistasis and gye
and also important factors that add
to the ignorant variability of this
phenomenon
since we already know that the effects
of disease resistance are variable
and are case specific i am focusing on
three
uh specific or overarching questions
to measure the direction on magnitude
of the potential effect of energy
resistance
specifically that is is it positive
is it negative or is it neutral
i am quantifying these potential effects
by
evaluating crop performance in the
presence of the disease the artificially
inoculated condition
and in the absence of the disease the
uninoculated
counterpart i am initially focusing on
three agronomic traits
yield stock lodging and maturity
i'm also interested in investigating
what are the effects of selection for
yield on nlp resistance and trade-offs
the problem is that through natural and
artificial selection
farmers and plant breeders have been
strongly selecting for
resistance alleles whose benefits
are the way the cost is biologically
sound
however this logic hasn't been tested
experimentally i wish to test this
hypothesis
taking advantage of the genomes to field
initiative
which is a testing hybrid populations
in many environments in north america
although my nlb trial
was planted over six years in a single
location here in new york estate
the g2f initiative provides unique
opportunities
to study several aspects of nlp
resistance
uh in mace hybrids so in the next slides
i will present my results
on agronomic effects association studies
and high throughput phenotyping
in the 2014 population alone
it seems that nlp resistance has no
yield penalty uh or in the
in the absence of the dc as revealed by
this a positive
slope from a regression between the
grain yield
measured in the uninoculated trial
and energy resistance as measured in the
inoculated
trial i observe a similar tendency
across years when looking at the hybrids
all together
the colored dots represent a specific
hybrid sets or groups and in the future
i will be checking the specific tendency
for each of them
but all in all these results are in
agreement
with a study with two studies
which report that selection for nlp
resistance didn't compromise the yield
potential
in the absence of this disease
uh in my exploratory uh association
study using only the 2014 hybrid
population
i didn't find significant
g was hits for nlp resistance however
this snip that stands out above this
towering on chromosome 8
seems to collocalize with a known num
nlpqtl and i expect that
improvements to the gwas models will
increase the power of this
study or this analysis
however i did detect significant
snips for grain moisture root lodging
and stock lodging under nlp pressure
so the stock lodging results are the
most interesting
because they resonate with a study
which report that selection for nlp
resistance reduces
stock lodging under nlv pressure
now in regard to the high throughput
high throughput phenotyping
i am extracting a multispectral
vegetation indices from
aerial images i am focusing on two
different types of
geoplasm neuroisogenic lines and of
course the g2f hybrids
although the germination was not uniform
and the soil background noise was high
in the
nil plot i decided to
start my analysis
in this particular gel plasm because
it contains integrations that harbor
key and lbqtls
i'm also using these vegetation indices
to study this is complex
these foliar disease complexes to
identify
multiple disease resistance resistant
lines
so i am a
[Music]
making the most of uh of uh
not of the natural occurrence of
northern leaf spot and anthracnose leaf
blight
plus the the artificial inoculated mlb
which is my target disease
to uh to assess
overall plant health i am using this
metric
a relative area under the disease
progress curve
which will represent the cumulative
effects
of of these three co-occurring diseases
i then compare this iudpc
to the indices that i extracted from the
areal images of my nil plots
the correlation between these two
metrics
showed that a significant a
negative relationship which makes sense
because they higher the nlp
the dc severity so the lower the
the index value uh it wasn't it was
interesting to see that the well-known
and widely used ndvi was outperformed
by the other vegetation
indices although significant
this correlation seems to be
low compared to the to those reported in
the literature
so i think that the uh relatively or the
high
background noise observed in the nil
plots contributed to these relatively
low correlations so i'm expecting that
when i analyze the
g2f plot which was highly uniform
these correlations are going to leak
are going to be stronger because the
soil background noise
won't be an issue
to wrap up my preliminary
results suggest that energy resistance
show no yield penalties
and may have some agronomic benefits for
example
stock lodging resistance the
multi-spectral
vegetation indices could be used for
high throughput phenotyping
of multiple disease resistance some of
my
future undertakings will include the
multi-year analysis of the
of the g2f hybrids and use the
vegetation
indices to improve the g-was models and
also
use them as year predictors to
study nlp trade-offs more accurately
and also include a spatial correction
and environmental
covariates in my statistical models
because the
inoculated and uninoculated trials
are located in distant fields in the
same farm
i like to express my gratitude to the my
special committee and and to all the
smart and kind people who have helped me
with my research
especially judy coltman who collected
the g2f field data that i used to put
together
this presentation this concludes my talk
uh thank you very much for your
attention
and i'll be happy to take uh questions
and buckler asks has hybrid vigor been
related to resistance
yes yes uh yeah that has been related to
resistance
uh yeah so i'm expecting to find some
good levels of
resistance in this hybrid uh population
yeah but i'm more interested of course
on
looking if the that resistance that
occurs
uh either naturally or through
artificial selection
has some uh deleterious effect on yield
so the
initial analysis seems that maybe
it's not deleterious when the disease is
not present
thank you and satia
arisa asks what was your g-wasp model
and the threshold for declaring
significant
mta and
yeah i use uh of course i corrected for
population structure and also included a
kinship matrix
on five pcs yeah but uh
sometimes it's very difficult to deal
with uh
nlp resistance initially so i wasn't
able to
to find significant g was hit in my
first geos models because the
uh phenotypic or the disease phenotypes
are usually skewed so i need to
improve or maybe resort to some
statistical tweaks but in the others
uh traits where i was able to identify
uh the g was significantly was hit
yeah i was able i use essentially the
same uh
gwas model and yeah i was successful in
getting
these uh significant hits
and i use of course bonferronian and
flash discovery rate as my trespasser
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu